I want to tell you a story about a girl
but I can't tell you her real name so
let's just call her hadiza hadiza is 20
she's shy but she has a beautiful smile
that lights up her face but she's in
constant pain and she will likely be on
medication for the rest of her life do
you want to know why her diva is a
chibok girl and on April 14 2014 she was
kidnapped by Boko Haram terrorists she
managed to escape though by jumping off
the truck that was carrying the girls
but when she landed she broke both her
legs and she had to crawl on her tummy
to hide in the bushes she told me she
was terrified that walkaround would come
back for her she was one of 57 girls who
would escape by jumping off trucks that
day the story quite rightly caused
ripples around the world people like
Michelle Obama
m'lila and others lent their voices in
protest and at about the same time I was
living in London at the time I was sent
from London to Abuja to cover the World
Economic Forum that Nigeria was hosting
for the first time but when we arrived
it was clear that there was only one
story in town we put the government
under pressure we asked tough questions
about what they were doing to bring
these girls back understandably they
weren't too happy with our line of
questioning and let's just say we
receive our fair share of alternative
facts influential Nigerians were telling
us at the time that we were naive we
didn't understand the political
situation in Nigeria but they also told
us that the story of the chibok girls
was a hoax
sadly this hoax narrative has persisted
and there are still people
today who believe that the chibok girls
were never kidnapped yet I was talking
to people like these devastated parents
who told us that on the day that Boko
Haram kidnapped their daughters they ran
into the sambisa forest after the trucks
carrying their daughters they were armed
with machetes but they were forced to
turn back because Boko Haram had guns
for two years inevitably the news agenda
moved on and for two years we didn't
hear much about the tip or girls
everyone presumed they were dead but in
April last year I was able to obtain
this video this is a still from the
video that Boko Haram filmed as a proof
of life and through a source I obtained
this video but before I could publish it
I had to travel to the northeast of
Nigeria to talk to the parent to verify
it I didn't have to wait too long for
confirmation one of the mothers when she
watched the video told me that if she
could have reached into the laptop and
pull out her child from the laptop she
would have done so for those of you
parents like myself in the audience you
can only imagine the anguish that that
mother felt this video would go on to
kickstart negotiation talks with Boko
Haram and a Nigerian senator told me
that because of this video they entered
into those talks because they have long
presumed that the chibok girls were dead
21 girls were freed in October last year
sadly nearly 200 of them still remain
missing I must confess that I have not
been a discussion at Observer covering
this story I am furious when I think
about the wasted opportunities to rescue
these girls I'm furious when I think
about what the parents have told me that
if these were daughters of the rich in
the powerful they would have been found
much earlier
and I'm furious that the hoax narrative
I firmly believe caused a delay was part
of the reason for the delay in their
return this illustrates to me the deadly
danger of fake news so what can we do
about it there are some very smart
people smart engineers at Google and
Facebook who are trying to use
technology to stop the spread of fake
news but beyond that I think everybody
here you and I we have a role to play in
that we are the ones who share the
content we are the ones to share the
stories online in this day and age where
all publishers and we have
responsibility in my job as a journalist
I check I verify I trust my gut but I
ask tough questions why is this person
telling me the story what do they have
to gain by sharing this information do
they have a hidden agenda
I really believe that we must all start
to ask tougher questions of information
that we discover online we research
shows that some of us don't even read
beyond headlines before we share stories
you here have done that I know I have
but what if we stop taking information
that we discover a face value what is we
stop to think about the consequence of
the information that we pass on and its
potential to incite violence or hatred
what is we stop to think about the
real-life consequences of the
information that we share thank you very
much for listening
[Music]